- So today's session is gonna be
what's new in Apache
Iceberg V3 and beyond.
My name's Ron Ortloff, I'm
a product manager at AWS.
I'm joined here today by Yuri Zarubin,
who is a principal software
engineer also at AWS.
So just a quick side note,
you're in an open source track session.
So this is what's new in Apache Iceberg.
More focused on open source
and what's new in the spec.
There are a bunch of other
Iceberg-focused sessions,
specifically on AWS services
leveraging V3 features,
things like deletion vectors.
There's a great session on
how you can use AWS services
with deletion vectors and a bunch more.
So just quick side note on that one.
So what are we gonna talk about today?
It's really Iceberg V3,
why should you care?
There's gonna be the three top features
that we see most of our
customers talking about:
the variant data type,
deletion vectors,
and row lineage.
Those are really kind of bubbling
up to the top of the stack
in terms of what people
are most interested in,
where they're seeing the most alignment
with their use cases.
We'll wrap up the V3 talk
with additional features.
There's a couple of buckets
of great additional features
that are in the V3 spec.
We'll talk a bit about those.
And then Yuri's gonna come on
and talk a bit more forward
looking about Apache Iceberg V4,
where the community's starting to go.
We're starting to see some proposals,
formulate some momentum
around those proposals
as things are starting to shape up
and look forward towards
Apache Iceberg V4.
We'll have call to action, some resources,
and then you'll be on your
merry way to your next session.
Okay, so before we get into V3,
I want to talk a little
bit about Apache Iceberg
as a project and the project history.
So everything started
back in 2017 at Netflix.
Dan Weeks, Ryan Blue,
Jason Reid noticed a lot
of common patterns around
the big data solutions
that they had at Netflix.
Started a project that
they called Iceberg.
In 2018, they started a process of getting
that moved into the Apache
Software Foundation.
So 2018, Iceberg became
an incubator project,
which is kind of the
first sort of toe step
into the Apache Software Foundation.
In 2020, it became a top level project.
So this is where you get
the formal governance,
and you're following
the Apache Software Foundation processes.
2021, that's when the version
two of the spec came out.
At that time, the big kind
of release and feature
that came in V2 was the
capability for merge-on-read.
So doing row level deletes,
which is kind of the
precursor to deletion vectors,
which is what we'll
talk about today for V3.
2025, so this year in May,
the version three of
the spec was ratified.
And then as I mentioned,
we're starting to see some formulation
around where things are going
with the end development proposals for V4.
So with that foundation established,
when it comes to Apache
Software Foundation projects,
there's a couple terms when
we're talking about versions
and what's new and those sorts of things
that it's important to
understand how things operate
within Apache Software Foundation.
So you have specifications,
those are basically documents.
It's a contract that
anybody that's working
with Iceberg needs to adhere to
to be spec compliant.
This is a little bit more
important, I believe,
in the Iceberg space
where interoperability is
really the golden ticket
of why Iceberg has gained
so much popularity.
You have multiple vendors implementing,
you wanna make sure that
you're adhering to a spec
so that you can have
that single copy of data
and use a bunch of
different compute engines
on top of that data.
So specifications are just that contract.
They have to be voted on by the PMC,
so the project management committee,
before they're officially ratified.
But keep in mind, anybody that wants
to participate in an Apache project
is more than welcome to vote.
Have your voice heard.
Something you really want
to champion, go vote for it.
Something you wanna provide
feedback on, go vote for it.
Everybody's welcome to participate.
Only the PMC member votes count though.
On the release side, this
is where the specs start
to come to life.
So you have spec features that
are implemented in releases,
either through reference
implementations or SDKs,
but the releases go through
a formal Apache Software Foundation
software release process.
Those, again, are voted on by
the PMC just like specs are.
So why is this important?
So a lot of people heard
a lot of marketing buzz,
a lot of talk about the
Iceberg V3 spec being released
back in May, and they were like,
"Well hey, where are my features?
Why can't I go use feature X, Y,
and Z that I heard someone talk about
in the Iceberg V3 spec?"
So since the 1.7 release
all the way through up
to the 1.10 release,
this is where we're
seeing the community start
to implement those features
that were ratified in the spec.
So that's gonna continue to go forward,
but just keep note that there is a lag
between when things are ratified
in a spec in that contract
and when they actually make it
to market in a reference implementation
that you can get your hands on and use.
So that's kind of the
whole point of the slide,
giving some kind of foundation
on where things are at.
The V3 spec is not 100%
implemented in any release yet.
So that's really the kind of dry residue
on this whole slide.
Okay, so with that all out of
the way, let's jump into V3,
and let's start talking
about some of the features.
The first one we'll talk about
is the variant data type.
By the way, real quick show of hands,
how many people are using Iceberg today?
I meant to do this before, so...
Okay.
Anybody had a V3 table created yet?
We have one brave soul.
(audience laughing)
We gotta get this guy a prize.
(laughs) That's awesome, well done.
(audience applauding)
Okay, so come on up and join us.
You can give the rest
of the talk. (laughs)
Okay, so before we jump
into variant data type,
let's just do a quick background.
There's really a few different kinds
of data types in Iceberg.
There's primitive types.
These are atomic data types,
can't be broken down further.
Think of like int, string.
Those are your basic
atomic primitive types.
There's also structured types
where you can actually
stitch together multiple
of the primitive types.
Think list, map, array,
those types of things.
Key here is you have
a fixed schema though.
And then this is where
variant comes in now
with the ability to do
semi-structured data support.
So here you're getting flexibility
to handle a varying schema.
There is no fixed component
to the semi-structured nature
of variant.
We see a lot of people
leveraging variant data type
to handle and process JSON
data that they receive.
So in terms of components
in the variant spec,
for V3, there are three
different components.
There's a metadata component.
This is used to support
things like file pruning.
There's an encoding where
you're taking values out
of the variant data set and
putting a data type on those.
And then the last component is shredding.
So shredding is basically
taking elements out
of the variant data type,
the variant data set,
and materializing those as hidden columns.
We'll talk a bit more about
shredding here in a moment.
So before we get into use
cases of the variant data type,
let's talk a little bit about
some of the pain that some
of you folks that are using Iceberg V2
may be living through
today when you're trying
to handle semi-structured data.
So first thing we saw a lot of
customers doing is basically
trying to make their semi-structured data
look like structured data.
And they're doing that
through transformations,
picking the closest
structured type that they can
to align to their data.
And that's just how they're living, right?
With this, again, you have to
operate with a fixed schema.
There is a little bit less
profile on the performance
that we'll talk a bit
more about later as well.
But we do see some people trying
to operate in this manner,
and you're, again, also
paying for additional costs
around the transformation of that data.
Second pattern we see is
people just materializing out
additional columns.
So they may take in a data set,
find a number of elements
that are key to them,
and then they'll run transformations
and put them out into
separate columns in the table.
So again, you're paying
transformation costs, compute costs,
but you are getting pretty
good performance in this model.
These are legit columns in the
table that you've transformed
and pulled out of a semi-structured set.
They're gonna have stats on them,
they're gonna perform quite well.
And then the last one is string.
I call this kind of
like the give up model.
Like I've got a semi-structured data set,
I can't fit it into a struct,
I don't wanna materialize columns,
ah, let's just throw it
into a string field, right?
And we'll do string parsing, parse JSON,
we'll just grab data out of that thing
whenever we can, right?
This one, it gives you
that flexible schema.
But I do have performance
listed on here twice
because the penalty for this
can be quite substantial.
It really, really can.
So that's what we see
customers doing today.
In terms of use cases,
what we really see customers
going after with variant,
first one I'll talk
about is IoT workloads.
So here, you've got eventing-type models,
you've got different event details
that you may be getting from a number
of different IoT devices.
Schema is really best applied on read,
not trying to figure out a way to get
that data into a fixed schema upfront.
You also have a tendency to add in fields
into your semi-structured
data set more often
with IoT workloads as, again,
you're getting these
varieties of different types.
So this is a case where
variant being semi-structured
in nature can just absorb
that semi-structured type data
and give you an ability to report on it.
The next one is data pipelines.
So here, this is more
about landing the data,
land it into a variant data type,
and instead of doing transformation logic
to get it to fit into a schema,
you're basically building
logic into your data pipeline
to apply a schema.
So we had one customer,
they're taking in data from a
number of different suppliers.
They couldn't scale up the operation
to actually enforce schema
on their data providers.
So they basically had a data set.
If it fit into the schema, great.
It went in to the main
pipelines that they had.
If they didn't have a supplier
that gave them spec-compliant
data or schema-compliant data,
they created something they called
the imparsable fields column.
That was variant.
They would just dump the
data into that variant field
and use pipelines to
extract pipeline logic
to extract the elements
out of that variant field.
That allowed them then
to keep things consistent
as they moved the data
through the different phases in reporting
and analytics for their solution.
The last one is real time analytics.
So again, you want to be able
to query the data as it lands.
You wanna avoid pre-processing of data.
This is in a model where I need access,
and I need analytics on top
of the data immediately.
We had a fintech customer
doing lots of quote analysis:
stocks, bonds, crypto, whatever.
Those quotes all come in
in different shapes and sizes.
They don't have time for
this solution to be able
to do any pre-processing
or transforming up front.
They want to throw it into a variant field
and just let the quants
and the smarter people than
me query on that data quickly.
So that's variant use cases.
Just to distill down some
of the variant benefits.
Performance and cost is
really a big one with variant.
You're getting data put into
columnar in your storage,
which gives you stats,
gives you the ability to
do predicate push down.
We talked a lot about flexible schema
in the different use cases
and build up to this slide.
You're operating now on a
schema that's dynamic for you.
You get in new eventing
scenarios and details.
You almost get an automatic
schema evolution, right?
You can still take things in
that have new elements in them,
and you can still operate on top of them
without having to go through
a formal schema evolution.
Efficient storage.
So you are getting compression
when you do the shredding
and build out the hidden columns.
You're gonna get the
compression done for you
out of the box.
And then last benefit is
around querying the data.
So you get schema navigation
through dot notation on some engines,
some other engines have a
slightly different syntax,
but it's very easy to go through
and navigate down a hierarchy
on a variant data type
compared to wrapping multiple
string parsing functions
or anything like that.
So I've talked a couple
times about shredding.
Spoiler alert, this is my
favorite slide of the entire deck,
so be prepared to be wowed right here.
Okay, so shredding.
What is shredding?
So I have a table here that's
been defined in storage.
It's got event date, timestamp,
it's got source id as an integer.
And then I've created my event
details as a variant field.
So three columns, pretty simple.
I get in this type of data
file from my source system,
and I wanna load that now into the table.
So what happens in this case now with V3?
So the primitive types, those easily map,
get loaded through my
engine, put into the table.
Now with this variant field,
I'm going to pass that through logic
that you would have in
your Iceberg V3 engine
to actually shred that out.
So here's my handy dandy variant shredder.
That data flows through the shredder.
This is where it gets broken
out now into the sub columns.
So that's the engine implementation
of a variant shredding process.
And then those elements then
are put into sub columns,
hidden virtual sub columns in the table.
So you see SKU with integer
account, ID with integer,
and then you have the price in as decimal.
So I've got data types, I've
got these hidden columns.
I still reference that column
as event details, okay?
But now underneath the covers
and the implementation of variant,
I have those hidden sub columns
that I can then query into.
And that query would
look something like this.
Okay, so here with this predicate column,
I'm actually gonna be able
to do pruning on that data
and return just the values
that match that predicate.
Any other type of model
outside of variant,
there's a higher chance
I'm just gonna be doing
a full table scan,
especially if I'm doing
like string parsing
or something like that,
it will certainly be
doing a full table scan.
That's kind of rough
when you think about it.
But then also if you
think about doing joins,
if I wanted to do a join on
account ID to another table
with no statistics,
I think you guys know how
that story ends, right?
It can be pretty ugly.
Mismatched join conditions,
scanning multiple tables,
performance can be very, very bad.
Speaking of performance,
so just to give you kind of a rough sense,
kind of relative query
performance difference
that you may see,
with variant being the 1x baseline,
you could see up to four
times additional degradation
in performance with structured types.
Strings could be 10x worse,
and honestly that 10x number,
I could craft a benchmark
for you that did table scans
to very tight predicate lookups,
and it could be much,
much higher than 10x.
So just some ideas.
You start looking at variant
for potential semi-structured
type data solutions.
This is the type of performance profile
that you can start seeing over some
of those alternatives that we discussed.
Okay, so you're all experts
on variant now hopefully.
Let's move on to the next one
and talk a little bit more
about deletion vectors.
Okay, so deletion vectors
are a write optimization feature.
They're a storage optimization feature
that's been enhanced over
what's been in the spec
since the V2 version of it.
So how does the write modes
inside of Iceberg work?
You have the default
option of copy on write.
That's been there since
day one of Iceberg.
In that model, you have a data file,
you run a delete query against that,
and then you rewrite a new data file
that's got whatever was
deleted out of it removed.
So I use this analogy.
If I've got a table with 10 records in it,
and I want to delete one
of those records out,
I'm gonna rewrite a new data
file with nine records in it.
That's copy on write, okay?
Now that may not seem
like that big of a deal,
but if you do that across
thousands of data files,
your write amplification
will be enormous, right?
You'll be rewriting an awful lot of data.
Conversely with merge on read,
that same model now,
data file, delete query,
I'm just writing a delete
file with one record in it.
One positional delete, right?
Or one delete condition,
depending on the type of row
level delete I've implemented.
So the write amplification
problem is solved.
You're gonna have faster
writes with merge on read.
You're gonna be consuming less storage,
but you're gonna pay a tax on the read.
Okay, now I've gotta
join those delete files
to my full data files
to figure out what's
the filtered result set
to return, okay?
Copy on write, I've got a new
file with nine records in it.
I just need to scan that entire set
and not worry about putting it
together with anything else.
So that's copy on write, merge on read.
So when we talk about the delete types
that are there in Iceberg,
first we had in V2,
we introduced the equality
deletes capability.
So this is writing a
condition to a delete file
as you see here, like
Remove all user_id='ABC'
And then that delete condition is used
on the reads to filter out records.
This is pretty popular for
streaming workloads like Flink.
We see a lot of a equality
delete solutions using Flink.
And then the other piece
that was introduced in V2
was positional deletes.
So this, again, you're
writing a delete position
to a delete file,
and then you're using
that delete file on read
brought into a bitmap to then
filter out the result set.
So equality deletes were there in V2,
equality deletes are still
there in V3 spec, okay?
Positional deletes were there in V2,
those are not in V3 three.
They've been deprecated
and replaced with the
deletion vector feature
now in the V3 spec.
So instead of writing
positional delete files,
deletion vectors is updating
the values on a bitmap
and then persisting that bitmap to disc
in the form of a Puffin file.
So there's a slight nuance to that,
it's still positional deletes,
but it's in a much more optimized format
with deletion vectors.
So let's talk a little bit about use cases
and why you wanna implement
something like deletion vectors.
We talked about the write
amplification piece,
but there are other higher level scenarios
where deletion vectors can come into play.
So GDPR compliance,
we see a lot of people running
into write amplification
issues doing GDPR compliance.
Oftentimes when you're
removing information
about individuals can be different than
how the data's fully consumed
for other business purposes.
And that's where you end up
in these random write scenarios
where your write amplification
is very, very high.
So if you have to do GDPR deletes,
deletion vectors is a feature
that you should certainly look into.
Another one is data cleanup.
So we see people using a
medallion style architecture:
bronze, silver, gold,
where your bronze is more
of like a raw staging area.
You're gonna land a lot of data,
there's gonna be maybe a lot
of noise around that data.
You're gonna wanna do
a lot of data cleanup
on that bronze layer.
So that's where, again, deletion
vectors can come into play
and aid in the the write speeds
for those data cleanup
operations that you do.
And then the last one is
incremental data pipelines.
So if you're running merge statements
in your data pipelines,
you have a potential to be doing, again,
more of those random
write type of operations,
and here's where deletion
vectors can play very nicely
with merge operations.
Okay, so just a slide here then
to kind of understand a bit
how the moving parts operate
within deletion vectors.
So in this example here,
I've got a table with a couple snapshots
that are created on disk.
We've got snapshot one, snapshot two.
If I want to do another delete query,
so now I've got a data file
that I'm gonna produce,
and then I'm gonna have a bitmap
that I'm gonna go ahead and update.
So as part of that S3 transaction then,
we'll make sure that the data
file's committed on disc,
we'll make sure that the bitmap
is also committed on disc,
and then that transaction is
committed into my table, okay?
So when it comes time to
then consume that data,
we'll grab the data files,
we'll grab the bitmap,
and then we'll use that bitmap
to filter out the result set
as we're returning the data
to the calling application.
Okay, so to kind of wrap
up on deletion vectors,
comparing them to V2 positional deletes
and really help hopefully drive home
why this is such a great improvement.
So with positional delete files,
there was a propensity
to have a proliferation
of delete files.
There was no spec,
there was no guidance given
around producing delete files.
So we ended up, and we see with a lot
of customers using position deletes on V2,
they have just tons of these delete files.
Small transactions, small deletes,
small updates, small merge
statements, whatever.
There's tons and tons
of these delete files.
Puts an additional compaction burden.
You have to clean that data up,
fix up your underlying data files.
But that's one of the challenges
that we're certainly seeing with V2
and the positional deletes.
The other is the positional
delete files are translated
from a bitmap into a Parquet file,
and then on read, that is reversed, right?
You're pulling data off of a Parquet file,
and then you're building
a bitmap on the fly
to filter out results set.
With V3 then, a lot of
these challenges are solved.
Per the spec, you're only allowed
to produce the writer implementation.
You're only allowed to produce
one delete file per snapshot.
So it knocks off that problem
of all these small, tiny delete files.
The bitmap itself is also stored
in a Puffin file directly,
so there's no deconstruction
reconstruction process
that happens around that
bitmap and the Puffin file.
And the writers themselves
maintain that bitmap
while the write operations are happening.
So you have a fully efficient bitmap
that's being built and maintained.
Okay, that's deletion vectors.
Let's go ahead and talk a
little bit about row lineage.
So row lineage is really a
great change tracking feature
that's been brought to the V3 spec.
So the components of row
lineage within the spec,
there's a writer specification for you
to be a compliant Iceberg V3 writer.
You have to be producing record
level change information.
You can use, as a writer,
you can use Iceberg V3 metadata
to understand sequence numbers
and row IDs that have been
committed to snapshots.
But there is a responsibility
on the writer's side for you
to produce these change records
that allow for row lineage
to be consumed.
On the reader side,
there are new hidden columns added
to V3 tables that give you
that row lineage
information automatically.
So you get a row ID, and
you get a sequence number,
and that's on every single V3 record.
And then from an operational standpoint,
row lineage is a required feature.
So it's on by default, there's
no knob to turn it off,
and that information is just there,
and it's with you to consume.
The other thing I like about row lineage,
for those that have ever dealt
with like a split brain type scenario
where you've had state information
get out of sync with data,
it's really kind of neat,
a neat little side
benefit with row lineage,
the row lineage information
is stored right on the record.
So you have that row
lineage state information
in the snapshot in the
record in the table itself.
If you want to go do time travel,
you're gonna get the
time travel equivalent
of what that row lineage looked
like at the time you query.
So in terms of row lineage use cases,
the incremental processing, again,
this is really a nice
sweet spot for row lineage.
If you wanna be reading out of V3 tables
as an input into data pipelines,
you can leverage the sequence
numbers, the row IDs,
the information there that's on the rows
to understand what's changed as a source
to feed in to your pipelines.
Event lifecycle tracking
is also another good one.
You think of like an orders table, right?
An orders table goes through,
or an order, I should say,
event goes through a
series of changes, right?
It's been submitted, it's been
billed, it's been processed,
fulfilled, shipped out for
shipment, delivered, right?
You wanna understand what the lifecycle
or the state changes were.
Here, row lineage, each
one of those is gonna be on
that same row ID for that order.
You're gonna see the sequence
number increment each time,
and you'll be able to quickly
and easily stitch together what
that life cycle look like, right?
Slowly changing dimensions,
type two dimensions,
similar sort of model with those.
You could feed in row lineage information
to help build those types
of things out as well.
Debugging is another one.
Maybe not as flashy as some
of the other stuff on here,
but if you keep track of
that row lineage information
within the transformations that you do
and the data that you enrich
and build in your system,
you can then trace back
to how those calculations
came to be, right?
You can use the row id, you
can use the sequence number
for which you did the calculation,
and then you can be able to
trace back over those events
and understand how you got one
plus one equals seven, right?
Something like that.
And then lastly with row lineage,
it's a great compliance capability,
enabler I should say.
So you're gonna have a
sequence number stamped
on each modification to that table.
So you'll be able to
understand if someone went in
and updated my salary
and an employee's table
to $1 billion, right?
You'd be able to see that
sort of change of events
and trace back on those steps.
Okay, so couple clicks here
on how row lineage works.
So I have a table here,
it's got two columns in it:
first name, last name,
and then I've added in this
gray box, on the side of that,
that's the row lineage columns
that come automatically.
If I do a SELECT * star from the table,
I see f_name, l_name.
I don't see the row lineage
columns automatically.
But if I actually key those
in and select four columns,
you'll see all the information
like you see on the screen here.
So initial load, I put
two rows in the table,
and then I have the row ID
and sequence number equal
to one there.
On the next transaction at time
T2, I update Diego to Pablo,
and then we see the sequence_number
increment up to two.
And then for the third transaction here,
we'll ratchet up the
complexity a tiny bit.
You'll get a merge statement
that does a new row,
and then it updates Carlos to Chuck.
So here you see the new record added,
new row ID is generated.
And then the sequence numbers,
both of those come in as
sequence number three.
Some people when we talk
to them about this, like,
"Well hey, why is the new insert,
why shouldn't that be
sequence number one," right?
It's gonna be an increasing,
monotonically increasing number,
but it's gonna start at where
the current sequence number is
within that table,
which is important now when you want
to actually start consuming those changes.
So here on this select query,
if this is like when I was talking about
doing those incremental pipelines,
if this was a source query for you
to feed into a data pipeline,
you can keep track of that
max last sequence number
on each of the batches that
you run through, right?
So now when I come through, if I say hey,
where the sequence number is
greater than the last time
that I pulled,
I'm gonna get those last two records
that we saw come out
of that merge statement
with this example here.
So to close up on row lineage,
in the V2 spec, there was,
in the Spark implementation,
a procedure and a view
implementation for doing changelog.
So changelog is basically a mechanism
that does snapshot diffing.
So you're taking snapshot
at T1 and comparing that,
joining that together with snapshot T2
to understand what the differences are
between those two snapshots.
So if you could compare and contrast that
to the row lineage,
because row lineage is
basically doing the same type
of change tracking for you,
with changelogs in V2,
you're having to pay the compute costs
to do that snapshot diffing, right?
And with row lineage in V3,
those details are just stamped
right on the record for you.
There's no additional
compute, you just query those,
the writers are tracking it automatically.
Changelogs, you have view maintenance.
If you do schema evolution,
you have to make sure the changelogs
and the views are maintained correctly.
Row lineage, again,
that's done automatically.
Those metadata columns, the writers,
everything is done for you,
and that information is
there with zero config.
And then lastly,
if you think about
correlating changes over time,
over time travel queries,
over different snapshots,
if you want to be able to
do that with changelogs,
it can get a bit tricky
where you're having to
do an iterative approach
to comparing multiple snapshots over time.
Whereas with row lineage, now again,
because that information
is stamped on the records,
it's very easy for you to
stitch out the full lifecycle
of changes on straight up queries
as opposed to doing a bunch of joins.
Okay, so
to wrap things up on V3,
we'll cover some of the other stuff
that's been delivered in the spec.
So in terms of additional
features, there's really,
like I mentioned at the
start, there's two buckets.
There's a core
infrastructure set of changes
or features that came in on the V3 spec,
and then there's also some
additional data types.
So we'll take a minute here
to talk about the core
infrastructure pieces.
The first feature that came in the V3 spec
in the core infrastructure
area that talk about here
is default values.
So default values
inserts data
when there's no value specified.
So you're gonna create a table,
you're gonna specify for a
column what the default value is,
and then when you're
running your pipelines
or inserting your data,
if no value is specified,
you're using the default value
that's configured on the schema.
What's interesting about
the Iceberg implementation,
the default value itself
is stored in metadata.
So you're not persisting a constant value
in the file itself.
You're actually using the metadata on read
to replace the value
that wasn't specified.
So that's kind of a nifty little nuance,
being able to leverage Iceberg metadata
to get that default value
populated on the results set.
And then you're gonna get some conformity,
some ease of use around the fact
that the value is persisted
in the table metadata.
I've worked on systems
where you've had multiple
developers getting creative
with how they specify a default value.
Some people use negative one,
some people use some other value,
and it can become a mess, right?
Here, that default value is
stored right with the schema,
and you don't have to worry
about any sort of pipeline logic
or any sort of rules that
you want to implement
for replacing in default values.
Okay, next in the core infrastructure area
is table encryption keys.
So table encryption keys
gives you the ability
to specify an encryption key at the table
and at the metadata level.
It's gonna give you a
granular set of control
across your tables that
you need to encrypt.
You can also integrate that
encryption key with KMS.
It does support key rotation as well.
So you can rotate keys.
And then lastly on table encryption,
this is more of an advanced
feature for you to really align
with some elevated security
compliance requirements
on your data.
So it's gonna give you
more granular control,
allow you to integrate with KMS as well,
but also to get that
higher level of encryption
on your Iceberg data.
The last one I'll talk about
in the core infrastructure area
is the multi-argument transformations.
So with multi-argument transformations,
now you're able to specify
more than one field
in a transformation.
So transformations can
be used for partitioning,
or they can be used for sorting,
but this gives you a bit more control
in scenarios where you have a harder time
picking just one column,
you need more than one
column to actually help
with query scenarios,
help to avoid data skew.
But the net for
multi-argument transformations
is this is a performance feature.
So you'll be able to align
your end user query
patterns more efficiently
with specifying multiple
columns in those transformations
for partitioning as well as sorting.
Okay, and then the last
section we'll talk about on V3
is additional data types.
So the first one in this section
is nanosecond timestamps.
Nanosecond timestamps
have been talked about
in the Iceberg space for quite a while.
Well, probably a year before
the Iceberg V3 spec came to be.
We had customers that I've worked with
that have nanosecond timestamps
in their Parquet data
or from some other system,
and they want to be able
to keep that fidelity,
that precision as they move into Iceberg.
And it's been a pretty
big gap for quite a while.
So what you're getting is the
nanosecond timestamp support
for your high frequency, your
temporal type of workloads.
You're getting the increase
from the microsecond
to the nanosecond fidelity in Iceberg V3.
You're getting this both with
and without timestamp support as well.
In terms of workloads,
I think this one fits very nicely
into the streaming workloads
where you want to be able
to have more precise measurements
on frequently arriving data.
Okay, so the next one is the geo types.
So this is actually two types, one slide:
geography and geometry.
You're getting now support for location
and mapping queries with
the geography data type.
And then you're getting the
ability to do measurements
and shapes with the geometry data type.
So both of these data types,
separate implementation,
separate data types.
They do follow the open OGC standard.
So we have an open standard
following an open standard,
which is great.
And then I said a one plus
one equals three on this.
Like I think having the geography,
the geo data types inside of Iceberg
in V3 is really a killer feature.
You're getting geo enablement now on data
plus all the goodness that comes
with Iceberg around schema evolution,
time travel, and interoperability, right?
So now you have the power of Iceberg
and the power of geospatial on the data,
which I think is really great.
Last one I'll talk about, unknown.
Unknown is a little bit of
a cryptic implementation.
It's a kind of a null placeholder value,
so you're gonna get some protection now
if you're doing schema evolution,
and types or data doesn't exist in files,
you can use the unknown data type
as a known null
placeholder across engines.
Sometimes we see customers
running into issues
where the null handling isn't
always handled gracefully
across their Iceberg engines.
This is something that's
helping to combat that scenario.
And we've actually seen some extreme cases
where customers have
gone to rewriting data
to make sure that they're not breaking
their Iceberg implementations.
Okay, so with that, I
will hand it off to Yuri.
- Thank you.
- Yep.
- Okay, so clearly there's
a lot of features in V3,
and after Ron's excellent deep dive,
I think we have no excuse
not to know about it, right?
And so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna cover some
of the new things that the
community is cooking up in V4,
and then we're gonna just
close out the session
and do conclusions.
One thing to note is that all the stuff
that I'm about to talk about,
it hasn't been ratified.
So these are just proposals.
Community is still
thinking about what to do.
And the way I would actually
characterize the changes
so far is they're very
much performance based.
So focused on raw performance,
not jam packed full of features like V3.
So I'm just gonna quickly
go through some of these.
So let's start off with
improved column stats.
So if you're not familiar
with column statistics,
it's like this special
information about columns
that's stored inside of
the Iceberg metadata files,
and it helps query engines to
effectively scan data, right?
And one of the problems
with them right now is
that the way these stats are implemented
is not super efficient
in certain use cases,
especially if you have lots of columns.
And that's because when query
engines go and read them,
they have to deserialize these large maps,
which then creates memory pressure.
And so one of the things
that the community is thinking about
is just creating a proper
structure for these.
And that's gonna help
engines efficiently look
at particular stats that they care about.
If you're just using Iceberg like me,
all you really need to know is
that you're gonna get better performance
in certain use cases.
Next is the adaptive metadata tree.
So this is motivated by small
write and delete performance,
something that Ron
mentioned earlier, right?
So if you have lots of
small writes and/or deletes,
it can become problematic
because Iceberg kind of
has these layers, right?
Starting from the catalog
layer to the root,
then a JSON layer, and then
there's three more layers
where you got the manifest list, metadata,
and then the actual data file.
So every time you want to insert a file,
or you do some sort of an
update or write into your table,
you kinda have to go
through all of these layers,
and that can be inefficient.
And so the proposal is to
combine the manifest list
and the manifest together
into a single structure
that's gonna have these like
root nodes and leaf nodes.
It's a very long proposal,
which I'm not gonna go into,
but basically at the end of the day,
it's gonna skip one layer for
the small write use cases.
And again, if you're just using Iceberg,
this isn't really something
you're gonna think about.
Just know that you small write
performance is gonna improve
with V4 if this proposal goes through.
And so lastly is relative paths.
So this is actually super useful
because one common
problem with manifests is
that they contain absolute
paths to the Parquet files,
to the data files, right?
And the reason that's problematic
is that if you want to copy your table,
like if you have an Iceberg
table on general purpose S3,
and you just wanna copy it,
could be copying it to
a different S3 bucket,
it could be a different account,
could be a different
cloud storage provider,
you kind of run into this issue
because once you copy the actual files,
you can't actually read them,
or none of the query engines work
because the metadata files are referencing
the previous data files.
And so the fix to that is, well,
like it's in the name, right?
So it's to make paths relative.
And this is gonna be, I
think, a very useful feature,
especially if you're using something
like S3 replication, right,
where you're just replicating
your Iceberg table
to a different bucket for data
protection, backup, whatever.
With the relative paths,
you're gonna be able
to just query that data
without having to muck
around with manifest lists.
And that's about it.
So just to wrap things up,
Ron talked about the key V3 features,
which are deletion vectors, row lineage,
and variant data type.
Then he talked about the core features.
So the core functionalities
such as default values,
multi-argument transforms,
and the new types.
So the geo, nano, and the unknown.
And then I just went
through the V4 proposals.
So that's the improved
stats, adaptive metadata,
and relative paths.
We do invite you to go
and just try things out.
There's only one gentleman
at the beginning of this
that raised their hand when
asked if they tried out V3.
So we hope to kind of move
that number up, right?
So hopefully by at the end of this week,
once you go back, you
go try some of this out.
So whatever vendor you're using with,
ask them what V3 support do they have,
and then try converting
your table from V2 to V3.
And if you're interested more in Iceberg,
do join the community so
you can attend a meetup,
you can join us on the
mailing list on Slack,
or even make a contribution
if you're a developer.
And with that said...
Oops, I pressed the wrong button.
- There we go.
- Thank you for coming
and hope you enjoy the
rest of your re:Invent.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)